c'est analyser tout ce que la nature à
fabriquer de meilleurs depuis des
milliards d'années pour venir les
condensés dans des nouveaux modèles
urbains pionniers
[Musique]
oh
aujourd'hui nous vivons sur une petite
planète bleue qui est recouverte à 71%
d'océan et pourtant nous sommes des
terriens est ce qu'un jour nous
pourrions devenir des mets rien c'est à
dire des habitants de la mer et des
océans des habitants de cette petite
planète bleue qui aura réussi à régler
le climat à vivre en symbiose avec la
nature en passant de l'économie linéaire
qui produits qu'ils consomment qui jette
et qui génère de la dette pour créer
véritablement une économie circulaire
qui fait en sorte que tout ce qui est
produit et consommé soit recyclés en
boucle vertueuse c'est vilain sont
directement inspirés de l'analyse du
vivant en tant qu architecte je me suis
spécialisé dans ce qu'on appelle
aujourd'hui le biomimétisme
c'est à dire s'inspirer des formes des
structures de l'intelligence des
matériaux et de toutes les boucles de
rétroaction qui existe dans les
écosystèmes mature donc effectivement
nos projets sont de véritables
écosystèmes habitées je vous invite par
exemple à découvrir le projet aille
correa le projet aille corée a inspiré
d'une méduse bioluminescente est un
noeud chan ce coiffeur al'inverse d'un
skyscraper c'est à dire c'est une tour
inversée qui au lieu d'aller gratter le
ciel va gratter le fond des océans
on y entre par une grande marina qui
vient accueillir des chants dédiés à la
permaculture qui nourrit les habitants
de cette ville vous pourriez par exemple
enfilé un masque à branchies qui
viendrait casser les particules de co2
et d'oxygène pour en extraire justement
toutes les particules nécessaires pour
votre respiration vous pourriez vivre
dans une ville en fit bienne qui se
développe aussi bien au dessus du niveau
de l'eau quand du sus du niveau de l'eau
cette ville construite en algo plast
serait destiné à être qualifiés
c'est-à-dire à construire un
exosquelette exactement comme le font
tous les coquillages qui se trouvent
dans les océans
c'est une ville qui vivraient en totale
symbiose avec votre environnement où
l'être humain vivraient dans des espaces
intérieurs biophysique et son jardin
finalement serait constitué par les
baleines les ors et tous les poissons
qui vivraient en liberté autour de cette
ville le but
en 2050 là où nous serons 9 milliards
d'habitants sur
terre avant d'atteindre 12 milliards
annoncés pour 2100 c'est effectivement
exploiter tous les champs encore
aujourd'hui méconnu pour l'urbanisation
du futur explorer comment en respectant
la terre on peut également construire
sur la mer inventer des nouveaux modes
de vie qui soit vous et non pas aux
sédentaires mais bien à des nouveaux
nomades qui pourraient durant toute leur
vie
vivre en symbiose avec les océans ce
type de projet c'est ce que j'appelle
finalement des utopies concrètes c'est à
dire des projets fous des projets de
rêve mais qu'on peut réaliser à partir
des technologies existantes à partir de
l'innovation sociale souhaité
aujourd'hui par les citoyens et donc ce
sont des projets que j'espère construire
d'ici les dix prochaines années
[Musique]